I want people to get this perspective
like you have laws in place let's say
somebody was inciting or had some
influence or someone committing a crime
that they'll go after this person let's
switch this over to here these are
accomplices people who are helping open
a door for people to go towards dinner
fornication to go towards drugs to go
Source alcohol all the things that are
breaking the law of the crater that
happens in the earth and again this is
not to say like oh we're better than
these people this that and the other
they can be better tomorrow they can
come out imagine if Drake accepted the
dean the purpose of life and he got out
there imagine how much good he can do
come to the dean come to Islam if you
enjoyed this short clip visit the dean
show TV on to watch the full video